dans cette boulangerie versaillaise la
préparation des galettes a commencé
depuis quelques jours pour réaliser une
bonne galette des rois tout commence par
la pâte feuilletée
préparez tôt ce matin elle passe
plusieurs fois sous le laminoir
la pâte et
jusqu'à avoir l'épaisseur
[Musique]
c'est ensuite le moment du détailage
avec ce bâton Adrien peut découper
jusqu'à une trentaine de galettes après
un temps de repos au frais elle passe
sous les mains de Frédéric Rabin le
pâtissier on met un peu de dorure sur le
côté ça aide que les deux restes collés
ensemble pour pas que la garniture ne
frangipane
s'en est
les galettes sont ensuite garnies de la
traditionnelle frangipane à ne pas
confondre avec une crème aux amandes la
frangipane elle est préparée avec de la
crème pâtissière
cette année les fèves sont en
partenariat avec le château de
Versailles mais malheureusement aucune
technique pour la trouver à coup sûr
donc après on prend les deux dessus
on essaye que ce soit
identique
après on ramène dessus et là on appuie
pour ramener les bords
c'est le moment déchiqueter la galette
un geste technique pour fermer la
galette et empêcher la frangipane de
sortir
et après on peut après on peut les
enfourner en fait les galettes sont
enfournées pendant 45 minutes en tout
entre 5 et 7 heures sont nécessaires
pour réaliser une galette
[Musique]